hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the Kerbal space program
alright I've been wanting to get into
this game ever since I was on the TGS
podcast and they've been talking about
it and I have no idea how to really play
I've done a few of the training just so
I have an idea of what to do but at the
same time it seems obscenely complicated
and I am going to crash and die they've
already crashed once and that was just
in training so here we go I'm sure this
is gonna be fantastic
oh boy I can't I can't imagine that this
is gonna okay Vehicle Assembly Building
I guess it's a good place to start all
right we're gonna make our own spaceship
alright so there was different modes
there was like a similar treatment wait
where is it now it was here before in
training cemetery mode - okay nevermind
all right I need a command module and
knowing me I have to make it as cheap as
possible that looks like a nice cheap
one there and some sort of fuel tank but
but alright let's try to make this as
bomb-like as possible see it needs a
fuel tank and then it needs a rocket
that's the deal because it needs to be
able to
the fuel out of its ass and then it goes
up into space that's basically how it
works all the scientists will agree that
it's out of sass and there goes into
space now my only question is hello ah I
need some booster engines definitely
needs some booster engines that's good
right there see right here and then get
it kind of kind of in a triangular
triangularity fashion yeah right yeah
bring it that's actually pretty close
and then I yeah right there yeah that's
um yeah that's actually pretty good
looking good all right oh there was
symmetry I knew those symmetry mode but
ah well angle Snap is fine it's close
enough
all right so it's got the command module
let's see that's not very much
hmm uh yeah I don't need any Center
stuff
this isn't about centering this is about
getting into space on a budget control
here we go
SAS module yeah that's good okay um I
don't need that structural stability
enhancers who has time for that uh
hardpoint I guess maybe to give this
some badass you know Finn's going on cuz
I mean it looks a bit too pansy like my
only question is how can I make this
look more like a penis because as
everyone knows penises are the most
aerodynamic naturally occurring
structuring and oh yeah whatever
nevermind okay whatever this is
slap that I'll slap that bad boy on
there yeah yeah that's what I'm talking
about
haha alright this actually looks like
you can sorta maybe a little bit fly get
a nose cone on there a nose cone on the
nose cone maybe that up I'll put the
nose Cup
oh no oh why why ha ha ha this is not
gonna fly I I don't know that yet though
I do not know that yet hitchhikers
storage container alrighty then ah whoa
Oh get back on there get back on your
back on reset how do I get it back on oh
god what have I done
oh no I pulled it right off didn't mean
to uh uh where's it going I see some
green I see some green come on you there
we go okay it's on there ha ha oh that
was a close one
ok I think we don't need to mess with
any sort of science were re doing
science oh let's just get to the launch
platform and get this nightmare into
space
ok that looks pretty good alright as you
can see we're on our little Launchpad
here and oh my god well the last time oh
god no no oh no oh oh okay let's try
this it's more symmetrical clear the
launch pad and proceed oh oh god no what
am i doing
I can't space I don't know how to space
okay bill Kerman is still alive huh whoa
I thought him man Oh Evie eight oh he's
out of it oh he's out hey hey buddy huh
you got a don't need to be out here in
your spacey but good job in being smart
about things okay arm let's end the
flight and go back to the Vehicle
Assembly Building this this is not gonna
fly
I can tell it exploded on impact let's
uh now that can stay let's just try this
as basic as possible things are pretty
symmetrical is this gonna explode maybe
I should just hurry up and throttle up
well I still can okay bill Kerman come
on throttle up and go baby
what flew off oh did I forget the other
one on the other side I did didn't I
oh no can it still go do you have any
fuel left I don't think so oh I should
not be trusted with anything let's see
here oh yeah that one ah forgot about
that okay alright then I'm actually
gonna do a little sum here let's go to
symmetry mode oh wait what oh ah okay
okay get these fins out of here cuz
they're not doing jack doodlee what I
need is more fuel yeah I'll get that out
of there for a second and then let's get
this rock oh man I'm talking about
I don't know I'm talking about baby as
more like it I need a badass nose cone
of fear
how's it gonna stand like I don't know
how it stands oh is that what it's for
wait huh how do I get it to
is that how it balances I don't know and
yet again I do not care because we're on
a roll we're doing good so far let's
just keep on this track record it's
kinda balanced a bill
hi Bill Kerman you haven't died yet you
trust me with your life right you trust
me with your laughs that was a mistake
is happening
nothing's happening
what is happening it's just doing a lot
of smoke and bill you look pretty happy
they're hot bill you're gonna be just
fine let's try to do some here I'm
beginning to think that it's too heavy
or something not right some Nara hey
let's speed up in time here okay so I'm
now right okay we're gonna get this
eventually we're gonna get something up
into the air so far I've managed to make
a lot of things explode on the ground
get back on there
scroll up alright let's bring this down
and bring it right here okay it's gonna
be lightweight and awesome standard air
breathing engine
pieces found lying about I like the
sound of that alright okay now just very
simple couldn't be simpler it's
symmetrical it's lightweight maybe I
don't know it's night now make it day
come on make a date
daytime hey there we go okay day all
right perfect
and then we got jebediah coming up here
and
we're doing it we're going in this
baby's yeah look at him jebediah is so
happy yeah
it only took I don't know ten minutes to
finally settle it
yeah yeah you're a little too heavy
buddy yeah we're going down oh man I
can't believe it all we're why are we
tilting why are we supposed to tilt
I think that's how usually spaceships do
it they they start tilting and oh my god
this pad there's bad is bad this is bad
this is bad
go back go back go back I've tried to
adjust it manually up like the guy from
Apollo 11 I think I'm about to run out
of fuel
I'm probably bad but I'll make it into
space I know no not that way no not that
way no are we in space haha we're in
space we're totally out of fuel but I
mean heck we're still up here so a good
job everybody yeah everybody give
yourself ride on the back of round of
applause yeah yeah this is why we leave
it to the professionals and Nessen don't
do this on our own
well I mean instead of you know we could
actually fund NASA that would be nice
but oh well that's a whole nother
subject space it's the final frontier we
need to explore it I'm all out of fuel
wait what is it electrical is it what is
electrical hang on I get open oh that's
for the command module so the guy can
survive we're still flying up
acceleration in this planet does not
seem that high cuz we're decelerating in
a very very slow rate look it'll be so
happy let's get him out of the ship am i
oh oh no no Dada
no no I have doomed jebediah but he
looks so happy
use your pack fuel go somewhere get back
to the ship get back to the ship jump
and die you're gonna die
go back go jebin ah tada crazy fool
oh no I don't know how to make you go
okay let's let's end this nightmare wait
hang out I go back to this Oh God doh
alright let's build let's build
something else in triangular symmetry
mode I need a lot more fuel tank or fuel
but I also need rockets so let's try to
make it bill Oh true that all those are
a bit too big let's um
stick with these smaller ones okay so
basically these are gonna be the second
stage how do I want to make a second
stage okay these are these are second
stage rockets now these should be the
primary stage ah whatever it'll sort
it'll sort itself out ah whatever
that's my ah whatever it'll get there
okay so the only problem is this isn't
very stable
and I got an idea I dropped these down
so that they're the bottom and then I
make this part of the oh wait make that
the first stage and make that no II
backwards I got that backwards you guys
go up there you go down into and wait
hang and make another one and then the
primary rocket yes that's it okay
so now it'll stand on the platform okay
I think I'm actually getting better at
this maybe maybe not
but now this will actually stand on the
platform and it'll actually get all the
way in this space so the primary stages
of three rockets and then the secondary
stage will be the center rocket maybe
maybe maybe maybe maybe maybe I don't
care come on bill sorry about your
brother jebediah but uh wait a minute
hey that was those are the wrong that's
the wrong stage you could shut of a
how dare you and let's try not to
panic on the controls so that I make it
go all wobbly waving to guava to open up
with no babalawo blah blah blah Oh Oh
little small Corrections small
Corrections small Corrections
doing good so far halfway through the
first stage of fuel it's a much heavier
booked weight I saw there was a little
purple thing was that jebediah
jebediah coming for you brother brill
doesn't look too happy but he's coming
here all corrections no that's wrong
wait wait wait small
no that's going the wrong way
uh-huh Oh second-stage Go Go yes I got a
hit my I'm guessing that circle is my
target but up Oh Oh God
all right small small small small go no
no no no not now I look bad now don't
point turns around how do I make you go
the other way
come on come on oh come on bill bill
bill you okay bill the other side of a
match bill uh yeah bill I don't know
what to tell you bill you're flying
through space bill now you're falling
towards around bill get out
oh what the I could have been in here
the whole time
oh I got my own whoo
well this doesn't look good but at least
he can't see his doom of impending how
do I get out of this one ah screw it
screw it that does not work
restart flight I might do this except
it's gonna be hang on hang on hang on
hang on and we're going we need to do
this this stage first that was my
problem
foosh oh come on screw it I'm aiming for
that Tower
oh okay I think the lesson that we
learned here is that I cannot fly a
spaceship I cannot design it I cannot
fly it but I'm willing to learn so if
you'd like to see more write in the
comments below so thank you all so much
for watching click the annotation for
more videos it I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video
before